At.
So it's a great pleasure to be here,
particularly talking about a subject which unfortunately is now even more
important given the changing politics of the glow.
I'm going to talk about three major aspects.
The first,
I'm going to talk about climate change when I'm also going to talk about
population and development because as I'm going to explain,
I don't think you can do with climate change on its own.
Now this is a radical thoughts cause climate scientist only think about climate.
However,
I want you to think about all the aspects.
And so therefore I think there are four major challenges in the world apart from
Trump.
Okay?
Um,
so I promised myself I wouldn't,
I,
I lost it about 32 seconds.
Okay.
This is terrible,
right?
So climate change,
of course,
passionate about that.
But we also have to deal with global poverty.
We have to deal with environmental degradation because not everything is due to
climate change.
And of course global security.
So why are these important?
So less be serious development is essential because at the moment,
7 million children die needlessly every single year or preventable diseases and
starvation.
That's the population of Greater London.
700 million people go to bed feeling hungry every night and 1 billion people,
one in seven still do not have access to clean drinking water.
Okay?
So this is why we have to deal with all of these problems together.
Yeah.
So why is this the perfect storm?
And I'd love to say yes,
I invented this term,
I didn't,
John Bevington the previous uh,
chief science advisor to the UK government because what he noticed was that
according to the International Energy Authority,
energy demand is going to increase in the next 14 years by about 50% food is
also going to increase by about 50% and to feed that water has to increase by
30% because you need a lot of waters to create energy and food.
Right?
In the middle of this you have climate change and then you also have to external
pressures,
which is of course rapid development and population growth.
So let's start off with climate change.
Okay.
This is what I do,
a deep sigh.
There is nothing complicated about climate change.
It is just simple physics.
So I can do the whole Brian Cox thing.
It's physics.
Okay,
so
now you've got it.
The reason being is all that happens is the sun produces huge amounts of energy
through fusion,
basically burning hydrogen to make helium releases lots of energy and that
energy hits,
well,
sometimes the sunlight and sometimes it's this murky gray stuff we get in
London,
but we get most of the energy as sunlight.
Okay?
In the visible spectrum.
Now about one third of that bounces straight off into space of because of white
clouds and because of ice,
because of the Albedo,
it reflects it.
You will know that because I'm hopefully Google sent you or skiing through bonds
and to actually make yourself feel better about yourself so you can program
better.
Yes,
please tell me if it's true now.
Okay.
You all have to wear sunglasses because of the reflection of the sunlight off
the ice.
Okay,
so the Albedo of the earth means lots of sunlight is reflected.
Now the interesting thing is a little bit is absorbed by the atmosphere.
Luckily by ozone to ozone catches a little bit of the ultraviolet radiation and
stops you getting skin cancer and has allowed evolution to occur without too
much DNA damage.
But the rest of it passes through the atmospheres if it's not there.
Now,
if you imagine being on that tropical islands,
okay,
and you're lying out there and that sunlight is hitting you,
the visible light hits you and makes you feel hot.
Cause as it hits you,
it converts to heat.
And the same happens to the earth.
Earth warms up and radiates that heat out.
Now we know the earth radiates the heat out because it's imbalanced.
Otherwise the earth,
we're just continually continue to heat up and heat up and then burn up.
So it's imbalance.
However,
what we have here of the greenhouse gases,
which absorb a little bit of that heat and just keep it warm.
So jokingly early on about sort of doing some sort of communications,
I did a communications with a 13 year olds in a various high score comprehensive
score in west London.
And one of the kids after I was doing this lecture,
when it's like a Dubai,
I'm getting somewhere.
What do you mean?
He's like,
you do that?
Well,
the greenhouse gasses,
they're keeping me warm.
I went,
yes,
I'm getting somewhere.
And I said,
so what's climate change where it's like your mother?
Oh,
I'm not sure where it going here.
This could be problematic.
And went,
okay,
what do you mean are willing winter?
She comes in and puts a blank extra blanket on you and like you.
I said,
well,
does that do?
Oh yeah.
Well it makes me sweat.
Perfect analogy to what we're doing.
So at the greenhouse gases,
we're all obsessed by CO2,
but the major greenhouse gas in the atmosphere is water vapor.
Okay.
Followed by carbon dioxide,
methane,
nitrous oxide and CFCs.
This is the monologue observatory that shows CO2 wise every single year since
1958 when keeling started to measure it and we have now passed in 2016 the 400
parts per million by volume.
Now you're going to say really hurtful.
Does that mean,
so let's have a look at the past.
So this is ice cores.
This is 800,000 years ago,
so nearly a million years ago.
And as you can see,
this is me saying this is CO2.
These are the ice ages,
these are the warm periods.
This is poor person that works at minus five.
Aren't you glad you work at Google?
But this,
this is why it's so exciting.
You get these beautiful slice of ice from the ice cores from Antarctica and
Greenland that actually have bubbles.
These are ancient air trapped.
So as long as you can extract the air,
you have real air to say that's what it was like 200,000 years ago.
And as you can see,
it goes up and down from 200 parts per million to about two 80 parts per
million.
And yeah,
that's what we've done in the last hundred years.
Oops.
So we've uh,
increased CO2 by 40% and doubled methane.
Okay.
We're really trying hard here.
So the intergovernmental panel on climate change is mandated by the UN to every
five to six years.
Summarize the science.
I'm say I have all the chapters summarizing site.
Most interesting thing for you is that there is a summary for policy makers that
is a political document because all 192 countries in the UN have agreed to the
wording.
Okay,
lots of politics,
lots of movement,
et Cetera.
So the interesting thing is
all the countries have signed up to the actual summary for policy.
So what does this report say?
It basically says there's this huge weight of evidence for climate change.
This is the temperature curve for the whole planet measured for that last
hundred and 50 years.
Now,
if anybody shows you one curve,
disbelieve them,
because of course it's about weight of evidence.
So this is all these groups,
which is the Met Office.
It's Noah,
it's NASA have put all these together in different ways.
And as you can see,
strong warming of about one degree over the last hundred and 50 years.
Okay?
2016 I had to change this slide because hey,
what's 2015 was the warmest year on record.
Now it's 2016.
There is a pattern occurring over the last 10 years of my slides.
Um,
it's always last year,
which was the warmest,
this is the summary geographically or fat as you can see,
intense warming over the Amazonia,
uh,
North Africa and in the High Arctic of more than two degrees,
but that's just temperature.
Are there any other things that are going to tell us that this really happening?
Well,
you know,
I mentioned skiing and off.
See all like skiing.
Yeah.
Okay.
So northern hemisphere snow cover since 1980 has been dropping markedly.
Oops.
A CIS ice,
which of course the BBC love because Richard have a bun.
Loves to go up there and go,
look,
it's melting.
It's like,
yet it's summer.
Um,
they were okay.
Any excuse to get up to the Arctic.
And this is the most worrying one.
This is the heat content of the ocean.
Unlike the atmosphere that warms up and cools down very rapidly.
The ocean has a huge heat inertia and that's literally just going up and sea
level wise as you can see,
steadily increasing.
And the only good thing about sea level rise is that it is on the order of three
to four millimeters per year.
So it's not suddenly going to catch us out,
but we do need to plan.
If it starts to accelerate,
it might go up to nine millimeters per year.
That may not sound a lot,
but over a decade that makes a big difference to flood defenses and things like
that.
So that's great.
So the past seems to say we are having climate change and we know from lab
experiments and atmosphere experiments that greenhouse gases do absorb heat.
So how do we predict the future?
I mean this is the ridiculous stage.
We've got two whereby we expect scientists such as myself to be able to go in
the future.
I see.
So these are the models.
These are the models that basically gritted system has air atmosphere as the
ocean has land and they all interact with thermodynamics.
Okay.
We know all the equations or movement and motion.
We can do it quite well.
And the reason why you are here at Google is because of this huge increase in
computer power.
So this is the first assessment reports,
which was back in 1990 and yes,
Britain really was part of Europe.
Okay.
Physically.
Second one 95,
got a better improvement.
We then got to sort of,
uh,
the third one and the fourth one.
And as you can see now we're down to the fifth one.
We were about a hundred kilometer square for the resolution of these models.
That's because of the huge increase in computer power that we can now access.
The really scary thing though is actually,
um,
yeah,
the results haven't changed.
We've been,
we've put more things in,
we've added more subsections of the climate system and it still tells us the
same thing,
right?
So what does that tell us?
So
the problem is to predict the future,
you have to predict you locked by you Lord,
not just you.
I mean the whole world.
Okay.
So just people in general,
which is not that easy.
So what scientists do is they get to gray it,
gather a group of the great and the good economists because they know what
happens in the future and social scientists.
And then save white,
tell us stories or sorry,
technically scenarios for what the future would look like.
So this one here,
this is the business as usual.
Okay.
Uh,
I used to call that the George Bush model and now we're going to have to call it
the Trump model.
Okay.
Um,
which is we keep burning fossil fuels at the same rate as we're doing now and we
get to about four to six degrees by the end of the century.
Now this one is the most interesting one.
This blue one.
So this blue one is political.
So the complete failure of the negotiations in Copenhagen in 2009,
the politicians went away with one thing,
which was at least we agreed a two degree target.
It was like,
yeah,
why not 2.1,
why not nine point a 1.9?
Yeah.
Cause it sounded nice around and there was some sort of science underneath it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Not much.
Okay.
Particularly if you happen to be a low lying island state,
two degrees means your country will be flooded.
Okay.
But they agreed to degree.
So let's say to the scientist,
right?
Okay guys,
we need you to have a two degree scenario.
Show us what we need to do to make the world better.
Okay?
So this is this blue one,
I guess what the models if fed the whites,
a scenario guests,
what we keep it to two degrees.
Now I'm going to reveal to you what that means.
So the wonderful quote is limiting carbon emissions.
We've acquired substained and substantial effort that 2015 Paris agreement shows
you have to do this.
So that's your business as usual.
This is the emissions if we're going to actually keep it.
Now there are two major problems without the first one is by 2020 which I
believe he's only in three years time.
We have to start to cut global emissions by 3% per year,
which is more than we've been growing it.
Okay?
So we have to completely reverse the all tanker.
Good analogy.
And by 2017 and this is something that scientists don't tell you.
Yeah.
By 2017 we are have to have negative emissions.
Okay,
so let,
let's,
let's proceed that.
So that means the whole world does not emit any carbon or if it does,
it sneakily sucks it back in to their country somehow.
And then on top of that to make sure we hit the two degree target,
we have to suck out even more.
Okay.
Hmm.
So,
so that's the Paris to clean.
That is what all countries have signed up for.
Okay.
And I'll show you a bit later why even Obama didn't know how to actually do this
for the u s okay.
Right?
So why is climate change so insidious and problematic?
Because again,
less best thing about it,
if it gets about two degrees warmer than average in London,
are we really going to complain if gets about three or four degrees warmer than
the south coast of England,
that'd be quite good.
You know,
we could have the English river ever actually being like from southern France,
we can grow beautiful wine,
et Cetera.
Well,
the problem is that if you have climate change,
and by the way you have to squint a bit,
okay.
Or have lots of caffeine like I've had,
um,
there is climate change in there.
So I put the average up.
So this could be,
this could be rainfall,
this could be heat.
It doesn't matter whichever one you want,
you can pick.
Now the interesting thing is that every society has a coping range.
Okay.
I'll give you an example of London.
London's temperature coping range is zero degrees below zero.
It starts to fail.
And if there's that sort of our come in,
what is called,
it's white and fluffy.
Oh yeah,
snow.
Uh,
if you have snow,
the Tube trains refused to come out of this.
I'm not coming.
You know,
there's white stuff out there.
Okay.
Compare that with Toronto where,
yeah,
two meters.
Yeah.
Now we're having a,
a bit tough.
Okay.
And that's just in autumn.
So again,
different coping range and the upper range people start dying of heat related
illnesses in London at 26 and a half degrees,
that's a cold sauna.
Okay.
26 and a half.
Now in Athens,
it's 28 and a half degrees.
Okay.
So there are these built in things.
So if you don't change that,
this is what happens.
So again,
occasionally you have a flood or heat wave that goes beyond your coping range.
Okay?
That will happen.
But if you don't move the coping range or the infrastructure,
you get more of these events.
So just cause I thought I'll stick with your hometown.
So they are,
uh,
you're the big yellow dot.
Okay.
That's Google.
Um,
I couldn't make any smaller ones here.
Okay.
So they are,
Google has taken over most of candle.
Um,
so this is the picture of the temperature nominally at night in the heat wave in
2003.
Okay.
Uh,
this is why all the rich people live in Richmond.
Oh,
upon Thames.
Okay.
Including my CEO.
Right.
So
if we have a look,
the temperatures peaked both in July.
Uh,
then an early August we had the first recorded hundred degree Fahrenheit
temperature in England.
Yes.
So my texts and friends said,
oh,
spring,
my African friends went most of the year.
And why?
So why is this special?
But if look at the blue,
this blue dotted line is the death rate.
This is the increase in death rate.
The estimation is that through northern Europe,
35 to 70,000 people died of heat related complications due to the,
his heatwave.
Okay.
Now,
and I love the medics cause it's not,
you know,
it's not children.
It's not young people that are most vulnerable.
It's old people.
And not during the day is when they go to sleep.
They can't air rate themselves,
they can't hydrate themselves.
And that's when the complications kick it.
So what does the medics call this harvesting?
Because these poor people were going to die sometime near the future,
you know,
maybe five,
10,
15 years and they're just being taken a bit early due to the heat.
Now,
why doesn't this happen in let's say Texas every single summer?
Well,
cause they all have air conditioning.
Now.
We don't have air conditioning in most,
uh,
or people's homes and we certainly don't have it in people,
old people's homes.
Okay.
So again,
it's an adaptation and just to really,
uh,
make you pleased that you're in a nice air conditioned office here and you might
want to have a look at your home.
Um,
so this is the anomaly for 2003.
These are the model to temperatures for a northern Europe.
And so by 2014 that summer will be the average temperature for London.
So we better adapt.
And of course you still have extreme events of up to four degrees above that
baseline.
Okay.
Just because you've moved to baseline doesn't mean you don't get extreme events.
So we need to move out infrastructure.
So
Ooh,
sorry I had to do that.
Right.
Um,
so what are the main effects of climate change?
Cause I'm then going to go onto a bit of population and a bit of development.
So the first thing is more extreme floods,
droughts and heat waves and storms also in places that they haven't previously
been.
Cause when you heat up the planet you're actually expanding the climate zones.
So therefore you're moving climate zones into new areas that haven't previously
got these events
may lead to food and water insecurity.
One of the things about the Lancet report that we found was when we sat down
over two years with the great and the good at Ucl,
we realized that it wasn't doctors,
it wasn't the hospitals.
Actually the greatest threat to human health in the future is just access to
water.
And food.
Okay.
Once you've got that,
you can then build everything else onto him.
And the last one in which everybody talks about may lead to migration and
conflict.
I will flag up here that people do not like to move.
Okay?
People do not move unless they have to.
And with conflict,
the UN did a review of all the water dispute international water disputes in,
uh,
the world and they found that nearly 85% of those ended with a negotiated
treaty.
And we're peaceful.
Only 15% of those ended up in some sort of conflict.
And the UN's,
uh,
summary of this is the climate change doesn't cause conflict,
but if you want to really good excuse to having a conflict,
then water resources and things like that are very good excuse.
Okay?
So
it's this all because we've just got too many people on the planet.
Please do not take this advice.
And as I always point out,
um,
please less,
less not go back to the fashion.
Okay?
Okay.
So is it just because we've got too many people?
I mean,
I read the Daily Mail,
it tells me that there were loads of poor people out in the rest of the world.
Uh,
just making it worse for us.
Okay.
So how does population work?
So we have what's called the demographic transition.
So we start off with a traditional,
uh,
societies where you have high mortality rate.
So a large number of babies and mothers die,
um,
and therefore you have high fertility to match that out.
Okay?
So you may have eight babies per mother and two of them make it to adulthood.
Now,
interestingly,
you need to point to in a society to have replacement,
okay?
So make sure that you keep the population stable.
So you have very low population growth in the fifties,
due to the huge acceleration of society and capitalism,
we then had huge changes in medicine.
Most of the major diseases were vaccinated against or preventable.
Okay?
Amazing.
So what happened is mortality rate crashed.
Okay?
So therefore low mortality,
but society still had high fertility,
huge population.
You then have women's education and empowerment.
Forget anybody that tells you it's about,
uh,
contraception.
We in this country and northern Europe went through the demographic transition
during the Victorian period with no pill and trust me,
you really wouldn't want the condoms of those days because there are only for
the rich and they're made out of,
I believe it was sheeps.
Bladder.
Okay.
Right?
So we can do this and what the key is,
women's education up to secondary school level.
Okay?
Now I,
when I teach this to my students,
I have to look at the guys and apologize to them because they all think they're
in control,
okay?
They think they think they're in control.
Lots of things off their fertility.
How many children getting,
yeah,
no.
You know how to tell you this.
It is women who are in control once they understand their fertility.
Okay?
So all of this went horribly wrong in the 1960s and we had 2% growth in
population during that period of time.
We are now below 1% and we're going to drop by the end of the century to a
negative.
We're going to have some shrinkage.
So the world population is expected to hit about nine and a bit billion by the
middle of the century.
Okay.
We're at 7.4 now.
So that is still an extra 2 billion people that we have to figure into our
society and how to actually feed them.
Now,
big problem here is that
up to very recently,
family planning was not on the international agenda.
Then Obama came in and the first thing he did was remove the gag law form all US
funding.
So that UN funding could be for family planning.
Trump,
I think it was day two.
Okay.
I think he was mucking up the CIA on the day one,
but day two,
first thing he did was put the gag law back and now it's even tougher,
which is any agency in the UN who even mentions family planning because family
planning in their eyes means abortion.
Um,
unfortunately won't get any US funding.
Okay.
So we're now back.
But the key thing is family planning is not about abortion sterilization or
contraception.
It is mainly about women's empowerment and women's education.
So now I've cheered you up.
Sorry.
Um,
so,
okay,
so we're going to have 10 billion people by the middle of the century.
Uh,
we've got rapid development and we could have temperature changes of over four
degrees,
but still haven't answered the question.
Is it because we all have those poor people,
you know,
those countries that aren't developed,
it's cause they're all those people causing all this pollution?
No,
it is because of consumption.
Okay.
So this is the total per capita emissions for different countries.
So we see,
hear us if we happen to be in Google in California,
yeah,
we will be.
Yeah.
Each of us 19 tons of carbon per person per year.
Okay.
Uh,
just by moving to London,
actually you only pollute by eight tons of carbon per person per year.
Okay.
And of course these are the protections for 2030,
so America is coming down Europe with all the strict regulation is coming down,
but of course UK may be leaving.
So that will go up again.
Uh,
China,
Brazil,
and India,
you know,
that two degree target I showed you.
And that wonderful curve to do that fairly
all countries have to be on the red line,
which is two tons of carbon per person per year.
Now just imagine you are a bomber with 19 tons per person per year and you're
looking at climate change as one of the serious things.
You now know how difficult it is to actually deal with climate change in a
political sense.
Okay.
So let's get political.
Perhaps it's just lack of money.
Okay.
You know,
perhaps we're just too poor to deal with this.
Okay.
Yeah,
I guess.
Well,
yeah,
that's GDP growth,
uh,
for the world.
Admittedly,
I did start it in the 16th and 17th century,
but you know,
it just literally is a straight up line.
And as you're here,
I thought I'd tell you.
So you,
UK,
d a GDP growth was two point $9 trillion last year.
That's how much money we made last year as a country.
So why do we have poor people?
Okay,
so I'm a geographer,
so therefore,
I'm sorry,
you could have a map.
So this is,
uh,
this is where the people are.
This is the money,
this is the people money know really even I can't get a correlation between
those two and I fudged a lot of things in my time.
Okay.
Right?
So this is,
I love this.
This is from Oxfam.
So the first thing is,
uh,
academic research has shown that the richest 1% of adults in 2014 owned 48% of
the world resources.
By 2015,
it was 50% bottom half owns less than 1% and
in 2010,
that was the same as 388 billionaires.
So 380 billionaires own the same as the bottom three and a half billion people.
It drops,
it drops and drops.
And in 2015,
shockingly,
it was 62 billionaires.
You had to get into a room about this site actually.
Yeah,
that's about,
yeah,
about that.
But this size,
those people own the same amount of wealth as 3.5 billion people.
So they redo the calculation this year and now it's down to eight people.
Okay.
Eight people own the wealth of the bottom half.
And You wonder why we have problems dealing with issues.
Right?
So not to leave you depressed and miserable going back to your work going,
Oh,
why did we bother?
Okay.
Cause I feel that would be really mean.
Um,
have to deal with students.
Undergraduates,
they're very sensitive people.
So solutions,
all the solutions exist.
Okay.
This is the ridiculous thing about climate change.
It is just pollution.
Okay?
All solutions exist.
We can deal with it.
So 50% of all the energy requirements for the world have yet to be built.
Okay?
Huge opportunity.
And therefore,
yeah.
Wind wave.
Solar.
Yeah.
Fusion.
Hm.
Well,
if we actually invested in it properly,
it might work,
but there are a couple of things stopping us.
So renewables are competitive against fossil fuels.
Okay?
Don't allow any economist to tell you they're not.
The reason they're not is because of the global subsidies.
So the International Monetary Fund,
you know,
that well known left wing think tank,
um,
suggest that the subsidies are about five point $3 trillion.
Okay?
So that's twice the GDP of the United Kingdom.
The fifth largest economy in the world,
still just so why?
But people think that fossil fuel companies are in the private sector.
It not true the big 25,
she was take the big 25 companies,
19 of them are either part or fully state owned.
Okay.
And therefore,
if you have a company that's producing huge amounts of,
uh,
petro dollars for your country,
you're going to get here.
So tax some tax back.
Yeah,
of course you can do that.
Yeah.
I'm not going to charge you anything.
Okay.
Again,
think about it.
I love the fact that Norway wants to go carbon neutral in the future except to
call stat oil,
which is owned by the Norwegian government,
means that they have the largest sovereign wealth fund of any country in the
world,
which is now about $250 billion.
Okay.
I have no idea how to spend that on the 7 million people in their country.
So,
however,
one of the big problems in developing a developed countries,
I apologize,
is not for fossil fuels and it is transport.
So in the UK building,
um,
sort of,
uh,
energy,
all of those are coming down slowly ratcheting down.
And I had to say,
look,
really,
really do you Joe,
I really going to buy that car.
I'm sorry.
You know,
so I'm here to say you don't have to push the whole global call.
Okay.
Because look,
these are to supercars.
Okay.
So that,
that's the for petrol.
Petrolheads starts the Porsche and that's the Mclaren's.
Uh,
they both suggests they can do not to 60 in 2.6 seconds than the Mclaren is 2.7
seconds.
But we won't say that.
Okay,
well German technology won't say anything about,
but how do they do that with an electric engine?
So these are hybrids,
seven electric engine that basically generates huge amount of talk,
takes them up to about 60 or 70 miles now.
And then after that they go petrol,
which then takes you up to 200 plus.
Okay.
So Tesla,
so again,
the future is electric.
Okay.
Because you can then generate all the electricity through green means and then
feed.
So hopefully in the next 20 years,
every single car you'll see outside here,
we'll have to be electric.
Okay?
By the way,
if you don't believe me,
look at the warfare that goes on for parking spaces outside Harvey Nicks.
Okay?
You have expensive Teslas and smart cars fighting for parking spaces because
electric cars get free parking spaces.
It's all about manipulating little wars and society.
So I want to give you,
Ooh,
oh,
that's okay.
There is a,
there was a map here.
It's gone.
Never mind.
Um,
then you see that.
So
the classic thing is that America is where we will win and lose the whole
climate change agenda.
Okay?
The reason being is because it produces second most Ma'am Sio two in the world
and where America goes,
everybody else follows.
So this is about high speed trains.
So at the moment,
China is building 11,000 miles of high speed trains.
Germany already has over a thousand miles and the u s has 456.
So this is a beautiful study by America 2050,
because you can get rid of almost all flights in the u s okay.
Overnight,
if you build a high speed railways.
And the thing is people assume that all the flights are from east to west and
west to east.
Absolute rubbish.
Most flights are within the small corridors up and down the coast to Chicago or
up and down bits of California or the northwest.
Okay.
Small hot flights that you don't need.
So again,
you can build railways 360 miles per hour and you could quite happily
remove 90% of all flights in the US.
Okay,
brilliant solution.
Hey,
and guess what?
It will produce jobs.
You would have to actually get the steel American steel companies up and running
to produce all the railway lines,
et cetera.
It's so beautifully ticks all the buttons except for Cole because they're not
steam powered trains.
Right?
So there are also market solutions.
You don't have to just hope this happens.
So again,
market solutions have been tried and tested.
So for Co two,
there are a number of ways you can do it.
The first one is that you,
uh,
tax the actual polluter.
Oh,
you give out permits.
So in Europe,
what's interesting is there is the emissions trading scheme whereby companies
have to trade permits.
And this trading scheme was incredibly successful in the u s when they were
trying to get rid of software,
dark side from power stations.
And it was the clean air act.
There were huge Christ that this was going to cost $8 billion to enact by
trading.
Uh,
meaning that the people that could clean up quickest and fastest and most
efficient the deed first and customer billion dollars to clean up all of their
power stations and stop acid rain.
You can embed the cost in the actual item.
So if you have a high carbon,
uh,
item,
then it has an extra whack of dosh in there.
And what you should do is then you pull all of that money back into the treasury
and you give it back out to schemes that reduce CEO to simple economics.
Okay?
It means that you punish the people and the items that you don't want.
You drive innovation because people suddenly find out a way to do it.
Oh,
by the way,
if you want to make your fortune not just here at Google,
okay?
He wants to make your fortune.
If you can invent an additive for concrete,
okay?
So at the moment concrete,
you take all the bits and pieces and you put it into gas burners and you have to
heat it up to 1,400 degrees Celsius,
okay?
Which then makes an aggregate,
which makes concrete,
which built almost a single building in the world.
If you can get it down to heating it up only to 900 degrees with a magic
ingredient,
guess what?
We can then use electricity.
We can use heaters and therefore you wouldn't need all those gas burners.
So Co because concrete is one of the biggest,
uh,
CO2 emitters both by production and by,
a movement around the country.
Okay?
So if you have a great clan and you can sprinkle some magic dust in there,
that's,
so those are the sort of innovations we need to really draw the actual system
down now.
So how do you embed this in?
So of course there's these whole move now to progressive,
inclusive capitalism.
Whether it was last year,
I'm not sure about this year.
So,
but the,
the idea you have the triple bottom line.
So you have the economics.
So you have to actually have companies which are a healthy initative that grow,
employ more people.
But at the same time you,
you and governments have to understand that you have to deal with the social to
make sure that there are a supports for everybody and you then have to deal with
the environment and make sure you actually can put all those together.
Now the ridiculous thing is that if you look at post Second World War,
it was realized by governments that markets work cause of the failure between
the wars.
So all governments interfered with the economics and international economics to
help set exchange rates until the ATS where then that was removed through near
liberalism.
And the interesting thing is they call it progressive inclusive capitalism.
Bizarrely enough as far as I can tell,
it's just social democracy.
Okay.
Name a name for a new century.
So I'm going to leave you with a couple of thoughts.
It's a climate change is one of the major four issues of this century.
But you cannot deal with climate change without dealing with the other four,
the other three.
Okay.
You need to be able to win win solutions for all of it.
Well,
so this is a wonderful cartoon by Joe Pat that came out in us today in 2009
because this was just the great Copenhagen sort of a a conference.
We're all going to love each other.
It was all going to be so much better.
And actually interestingly a Bama mocked it up and the reason why he mucked it
up was because the NSA was listening in and actually accessing everybody
Dropbox.
So don't use Dropbox.
Um,
cause the NSA is listening and they basically,
you took everybody's negotiation notes and the US knew exactly what everybody
else was doing at Copenhagen.
Okay.
Colleagues of mine spend our time with developing countries,
telling them not to use Dropbox and certain other things and how to actually
encrypt and make sure that they keep their negotiation stance a little bit more
secret than Copenhagen.
But that's by the,
by.
Well,
I'm sorry,
I just think we could,
if we deal with climate change happen,
energy independence,
why should we be beholden on Russian gas,
preserve the main foyer,
sustainability,
green jobs,
livable cities,
renewables,
clean Walter air,
healthy children,
et cetera.
And ass somebody says,
what if it's a big hoax and we've created a better world for nothing.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
thank you very much.
So we do have time for questions.
Please wait for the microphone.
Yup.
Um,
by the way,
feel free to ask any questions about climate change.
There are no stupid questions in climate change.
Yeah.
So I read the very interesting book.
It's called results.
What air probably,
you know,
read by David McKay and basically make some calculations about what we actually
need to do to say my Britain hundred percent renewables.
And the short answer is very hard and you know,
so I run,
the one thing you didn't mention is nuclear energy.
So what's your position on that?
Okay,
so
two questions in there.
Is it really hard to turn the whole of the UK into a Newell's?
Yes,
it is.
Because you need 20% baseline that you can rely on.
Okay.
So you can have 80% which is wind or solar,
which comes and goes,
et cetera.
Hence why people are interested in title titles.
Research is about 20 years behind wind.
Okay.
So the problem is that it's not very well developed.
You need that 20% because,
uh,
when you lot are watching and the one I have to say,
um,
uh,
yeah,
more like this one.
So I always,
for the students,
I always say,
just think it's the World Cup final England are playing Germany.
It's a fantasy,
but we're playing,
okay.
Uh,
England one kneel down at half time on what do you do?
Everybody goes and switches the catalog.
So the national grid literally watches TV and has the radio times in front of
them for when they had to switch on that base load to be able to cope with your
huge demand when you need your beer,
cup of tea,
et Cetera,
at half time.
Okay.
Or interesting enough,
as soon as strictly finishes.
Okay.
That there are some major peaks in there.
So that's how they do.
So yes,
it is difficult.
But at the moment we have a mixture,
which means that from anything from about 15 up to 25% every day is already
renewables.
Okay.
So we're starting to do that.
The nuclear question,
the new question is problematic.
So I always take a nice sidestep and say if you live in a democracy,
then your democracy has to decide whether the risks are worth taking.
Okay.
There are two things to remember about nuclear.
It is relatively carbon free when it's producing,
but remember it is one of the largest balls of concrete ever constructed.
You also have to ship the uranium unless you have a fast breeder and then you
even more worried,
um,
from other countries.
And also we have no idea what the carbon footprint of storing the material for
the next 10,000 years.
Okay.
So you can play with your carbon footprint or nuclear,
however you like to make it nice or not nice.
But my answer is usually it's democracies that decide.
So in Germany they had decided that that is not the route they want to go down.
Whereas in France they went,
yeah.
And basically they have a major problem which is they have to now work out how
to afford new nuclear power plants because about 80% of their fuel comes,
uh,
energy comes from nuclear.
That was a wonderful getter.
Next question.
Yup.
So I read an article some days ago about CEO not veen CO2,
sorry,
uh,
not being the real measure of we impact um,
global warming and you said something about it.
So is there any other variable that we can somehow measure and see,
um,
that is causing global warming?
That is not CEO too.
Right.
Okay.
So you will see that there are different measures.
So there is how much chu is in the atmosphere,
which is actually a pretty good measure cause it is the major greenhouse gas.
Okay.
In the models when you see that there is,
let's say there's four degrees warming the models,
we're all agreed that only half of that is direct warming form CO2,
methane and the other pollutant greenhouse gases.
The other half is form water vapor because there's a positive feedback about
half the warming we get in all the models is because as we heat up the planet,
more moisture in the atmosphere that heats up.
So those are the little wonderful models within models that we run.
So that's,
that's that bit second bay is there are other ways of actually putting all the
greenhouse gases together,
but not water vapor called CO2 equivalent.
And so what they do is they take methane CFCs,
nitrous oxides,
and they work out the warming potential.
So every methane is 21 times more powerful than CO2 at holding heat.
Luckily it's only in the billions,
whereas [inaudible] is in the millions and then you add them all up and that
gives you a total greenhouse loading.
That helps.
So the problem is there,
Nicole scientists don't tell that to people.
So whether you're talking about CO2 or co two equivalents and the other one
that's also naughty as people caught talk about carbon tonic,
which of course the amount of carbon in the atmosphere in tons is different from
the amount of Sia too.
Because of course you've got two oxygens.
Okay.
So there are lots of different measures,
but you can quite happily move between them.
Um,
and actually the end of the day it's all going up and it's all going to hell.
So no,
it was different.
And so I have a question.
Um,
so,
uh,
so the unfortunately still people who think that climate change is either not
influenced by humans at all or,
uh,
a complete fabrication.
Uh,
do you talk to these people and some of them might even policy makers.
So you talked to these people and how do you talk to me?
So,
um,
there is a group of skeptics.
They're becoming much older and shrinking in number.
Um,
so the first book that I wrote,
so the,
the version you have,
the red one a is actually a edition three.
And the weird thing is I've had to rewrite the book because so much changes in
climate change.
So the first one came out in 2004 and it was written because there was so many
questions that normal people had about climate change and things about the
history of it,
of how the politics.
So I put that all together.
A lot of us engage constantly with the public,
the media.
And there is a,
I would say there was a,
a small cabal of about 20 scientists in the UK that regularly engaged to try to
block or counter,
uh,
ridiculous statements from the skeptics.
Um,
uh,
again,
I perhaps I shouldn't say this on camera,
but you know,
I'm on Twitter and occasionally when I'm bored,
when my daughter is having a swimming lesson,
I will just basically pick a fight with a skeptic on Twitter.
I'm bored.
Climate change is real.
Ha ha ha.
No,
it was something that,
so we all do,
we have different approaches.
So Richard Bets at the Met Office is incredibly polite and conciliatory and
we'll basically invite them over for dinner and things like that.
They still don't change their mind.
I'm slightly less friendly,
so yeah,
but we do it.
There's a huge amount.
It's actually easier here.
I gain,
I have utmost respect for my colleagues in the U s who deal with it in the US
because it is vicious.
What would you recommend as a cause of action for us as individuals who sort of
believe in this course?
Right?
So the individual actions are problematic.
The reason being is because,
not because I don't think that you should try to be aware of your own carbon
footprint and influence the people around you.
But the big problem is that if we all went and lived in Wales in a commune
intense with a link to Google,
um,
the problem then is our carbon footprint.
We don't need drop by half.
The reason being is half the pollution that we emit every year is done by the
government on our behalf.
Hospitals where welds,
uh,
all of that.
Okay.
So the key thing is actually being able to live as good as we can.
So again,
move towards a more vegetarian diet is usually a very good one for your health
and for sort of how the environment at try to cut down on your,
uh,
flights.
If you can and try to do that,
have a better house or if that's great,
but actually the most important thing you can do is work through the democratic
system and make sure you have policy makers in place that are going to make a
difference.
Now the interesting thing is for a good 15 years when we had Tony Blair and
Gordon Brown,
they were obsessed with climate change and it went into every single layer of
government.
And even after two,
uh,
other governments,
they're still all that regulation that they're still trying to unpick.
So again,
actually policymaking is where it is.
I'd say it's actually being a voter or making sure your local MP knows that you
care about this passionately.
Yeah,
you pretty much answered my question.
Um,
I want us to talk about factory farming and how much influence that has in your
opinion.
Right.
So farming is a double edge sword.
Okay.
It's a nightmare.
So I'll give you as much as I can.
Firstly,
uh,
industrialized farming,
like factory farming is highly,
uh,
fossil fuel intensive.
Again,
heating,
lighting,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And also interestingly,
cows under that system produce a lot of methane from both ends.
My daughter loves this that they make the more from the front than the back.
Ashley.
Um,
so huge carbon footprint,
but catch 22 is that we're going to have an extra 2 billion people in the world.
And actually the green revolution that happened in South America and Asia are
great,
didn't happen in Africa so much that we need to actually deal with that.
The poor miss.
If we're going to produce enough food in the future,
we need to help them industrialized air farming,
which is going to produce more CEO to a more methane.
So it's that catch 22.
Yes,
in this country we could do farming in a much Greenaway and produce less co two
brilliant and we'll still produce the same amount of food,
but we're also then going to have to try and help other countries
industrialized.
They're farming in perhaps the greenest way they can.
So does that answer your question?
It is a problem.
It is a nice one that we need to actually deal with.
But actually the solution is also complicated by there being a growth in
population time for one more question,
two more questions
just to follow on from that,
but maybe to ask a question that's a little closer to home.
How do you view the growth of the IT sector?
Is that a problem or is that a solution?
So well,
interesting thing.
So I,
I am on a corporate social responsibility board for big it company,
uh,
set for Australia in French.
Um,
but mainly Europe and India.
And so again,
the interesting thing is that it has a really interesting intersection.
One because firstly you do produce a lot of carbon basically cause you have
server farms,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And it's interesting that lots of companies like Amazon are actually making sure
that those have as low footprint as possible.
Williams.
Second thing is what we found and I've got a,
I was telling,
um,
yeah and I have a spinout company set out and Harwell because companies want to
be green.
Okay.
That's the first thing.
They want to manage them environmental resources.
But they are because they know that also it makes financial sense.
It saves them money as well as everything else.
The problem they have in this day and age is lack of knowledge because there's
so much data.
So it companies absolutely essential because again,
if you want to measure your CEO to footprint of your company,
most companies go,
I make widgets,
how am I going to do that?
And that's when it comes in and actually be able to automate knowledge and data
and how you produce it.
So,
um,
interestingly enough,
I think it is right at the heart of this because if you have data and you start
measuring things,
things get better.
We found that with the Millennium Development Goals Globally,
if people start measuring something,
people then start focusing on it and go,
Ooh,
now that's bad.
Right?
Okay,
we can move it on.
So yeah,
right at the heart
and know that it wasn't,
because I'm at Google,
we have server farms and we try and keep
a quick question.
Do you think we all manage to stay at a two degree world?
Oh,
thank you.
So just,
just put me on the spot here.
Um,
honestly,
the conversations that scientists have is highly unlikely we are going to stay
to a two degree world.
The most obvious thing was that four years ago,
uh,
Oxford organized a conference called living in a four degree world.
Okay.
And the problem there is that this wasn't mentally before Paris.
So Paris has given us some hope.
I mean,
Paris even talks about having a one and a half degree target.
Okay.
I mean,
I can barely work out how to get to a two degree target.
And that's myth.
Me being world dictator.
Okay.
Um,
no idea how to get to one and a half.
We're unlikely to hit the two degree target.
However,
my view is how close we can come to that and be as far away from four degrees or
six degrees as possible.
The better.
So as a target,
brilliant.
If we miss it by a small amount or even half a degree,
um,
I'm,
I will be happy.
Okay.
But no,
we're not ever going to make the two degree target.
Thank you very much.
Professor Mark [inaudible].